l'un des cinq tomes
c'étaient les petits châteaux il tombe
dedans vous connaissez certainement
c'est le deuxième site de bourgogne le
plus visité avec ses trois cent mille
visiteurs c'est un incontournable de
l'été mais je vous propose de découvrir
des facettes plus méconnus
tapi dans une clairière à un kilomètre
du site principal
voici le dernier né de guédelon un
moulin hydraulique comme on en fabrique
et au xiiie siècle
pendant deux ans les charpentiers les
forgerons et les tailleurs de pierre ont
travaillé sur ce projet ils ont
collaboré avec des archéologues qui ont
retrouvé des vestiges de moulins
médiévaux dans le jura c'est donc une
réplique expérimental que philippe fait
fonctionner depuis quelques semaines
c'est assez compliqué en ce sens on
devient pas meunier du jour au lendemain
c'est les petits détails de à peaufiner
et puis arrivèrent j'espère aussi avoir
un peu plus d'eau dans maradan ma
réserve en continu et là on va faire des
progrès on va améliorer la mouture
la cuisinière du château et le boulanger
utilisent déjà la farine de philippe
dans leur préparation
les visiteurs peuvent parfois les voir à
l'oeuvre dans la cuisine du logis et
même goûter leur production ce jour là
max s'attelle à une fournée dont la plus
pure tradition médiévale sans levure
chimique un savoir-faire à retrouver
mais au goût incomparable c'est un les
odeurs le goût que quand en plein été on
se promène dans les champs de blé tu le
soleil a bien tapé dessus toute la
journée et qu'on traverse un champ d les
odeurs agréables de doute pas le pas il
est déjà dans le champ donc nous notre
défi c'est de l'amener jusqu'à la table
jusqu'au palais à guédelon il est aussi
possible de mettre la main à la pâte
ces collégiens jurassien s'initie à la
taille de pierre
des ateliers pédagogiques qui séduisent
une bonne partie des cinquante mille ans
font que le chantier reçoit chaque année
ici on touche du doigt ce que l'on
évoque en cours parce que six mois après
sa casse de l'école
l'as outreau c'est sûr c'est plus
convenue mais comment visiter guédelon
sans admirer les tailleurs de pierre en
plein travail
chaque année ces artisans réserve aux
visiteurs son lot de surprises
de leurs mains jahier en ce moment la
chapelle du château
la particularité pour nous c'est qu'il
va y avoir du travail un peu plus fin
que d'habitude il va y avoir on a déjà
fait des belles choses dans les grandes
vous des grandes fenêtres mais là donc
c'est vraiment religieux donc qu'il va y
avoir des petites choses qu'on ne trouve
pas ailleurs
le lavabo il va y avoir une belle voûte
avec des moulures qu'on n'a pas fait
jusqu'à maintenant une fenêtre avec des
vitraux on va retrouver donc du travail
à ces fins des petites colonne est là on
va se faire plusieurs on va attaquer d
un beau programme de taille de pierre
le chantier est par définition évolutifs
c'est ce qui fait son charme
c'est aussi la meilleure politique de
fidélisation du public jusqu'en 2025 et
la date prévue pour l'achèvement du ch
est on a déjà des visiteurs qui
reviennent en moyenne tous les trois ans
est souvent d'ailleurs je croise des
gens qui bien oui on y est allés puis
finalement c'est à 5 ans il ya six ans
et c'est laventure de guédelon oui il
faut venir une fois par parents parce
qu'il se passe quand même pas mal de
choses et c'est surtout l'équipe qui
fait que qu'on peut toujours être
ambitieux
non
si chaque année les visiteurs vont de
nouveautés en découvertes c'est grâce
aux bâtisseurs de guédelon grâce à leur
force physique mais aussi la force de
leur imagination